[Music]
it took me a long time
some hard lessons to learn what i know
about chasing redemption
i was a wanted man with the price on my
head
but for now i was free
i was on the run with no home and no
country
bombay was a place where everyone
started new
look out
you're lucky i was here maybe in my
garden
definitely not there's too much they've
wanted me for that
what brings you to bombay lynn
nothing he'll have secrets
i'll show you mine if you show me yours
i'm number one guide in bombay thank you
but no yes sir
but only after three knows it is a true
no
this is
my home
this place is not working without
everyone helping each
other why do you have been sagarawada i
know what i did what i need to pay for
we still find a way to balance out bad
if you're a man who doesn't want trouble
you keep interested in company
when i ask something of you you will do
it
or this place will burn
everyone here is running away from
something
it doesn't work trust
me in serious trouble i'm not going back
empty-handed
you should have gone when you had the
chance
you can be free of anything but yourself
i guess i need to be running towards
something
not away from it
[Music]
you